Oh boy.
Oh boy!
OH BOY!
[Clunk]
OH BOY!!
[Whooshing sound]
[Dramatic music plays]
[Grunts]
[Gun cocks, gunshots]
[Gun cocks]
[Gunshots]
[Growling]
Knight: Come on! Bring it on!
[Growls]
Knight: *High-pitched* Mommy! Ah!
[Knocking on blocks]
[Muted scream]
OH GOD!
AHH!
AHHHH!
Ah...
[Laughs]
I just fell down!
*Muttering* Okay, anyway.
[Zapping sound]
Whoah!
[Kirby theme plays]
Hey! Hi!
What do I do? I don't know what to do!
Oh, god!
You better not come any closer!
Ohhh I'm gonna really give it to ya!
[Yelling]
Wha-pfft!
Fu-er- that was just warm-up! I just wanted to intimidate-
F-ah- I'm coming at you eventually!
[Grunting] AHHH!
Wha-
[Whooshing sounds]
Oh! Oh jeez.
Oh, I gotta keep up the speed, keep up the speed,
keep up the speed!
Wooh! Wooh!
Auh, my fingers are cramping!
Hokay, fingers crampin'!
Eugh, don't slow down! [x5]
AHHH!
[Heavy panting]
Alright then, give this another go!
AHHH!
Floof the hair!
FOR POWER!
You ain't gonna get past MY defense!
I've improved the strength of my buttcheeks [slap]
and you ain't NEVER gon-
Ohhh my god!
Wha- Oh god!
Ahahaha! I know how to beat you.
Go, pelvic thrust!
[Squeak]
OH YEAH! BUTT SLAM COMBO!
[Squeaking and squishing]
[Happy Wheels victory music]
Hehehahahaha!
Wow.
God dammit, that was hard!
[Laughs] That was legitimately hard!
Ow, my hands!
[First video]
You better not come any closer!
Ohhh Imma really gonna give it to ya!
AHHH! [Gunshot]
[Second video]
-God! What're you doing outside my window?